- I've never had a Lunchable.
- I've wanted them, 'cause they
had like, cool commercials.
- I always thought they
looked like, Play-Doh?
- Cracker Stackers, this looks fun.
- A lot of fat, (laughs), that's cool.
- Oh, it comes with a drink.
- The meat is like, watery.
- Do I like, touch it?
- I have this block of sweaty cheese.
- I'm touching a dog's tongue.
- Half of this package is a Reese's cup.
- Can I put the Reese's on top?
- I would eat this, like, at a
field trip to the zoo or something.
- This is the one that I always saw
when I was a kid, the pizza one.
- I just love how future this is.
- The kind of food the astronauts eat.
- Ugh.
- This doesn't appeal to me.
- This is the other crust.
- That was kind of fun.
- A tiny bit of mozzarella on top.
- A giant nipple.
- Edible.
- I actually feel good
about this one.
- This would definitely
save you from a bully
if you gave it to him.
- Pancakes, they make breakfast?
- There's something that
some people might refer to as bacon.
- I wonder how long it's
been in this box? (cough)
- Upsettingly squishy.
- [Dark Haired Girl] Very weird.
- Just like a sponge.
- Eh.
- Oh my god, that was really good.
- This is fantastic, did
other people like this?
- (laughs) Did anyone like this?
- This is childhood
dream, just to like have
tiny pancakes that you dip,
and then you make a mess
and get all over your fingers
and then you touch stuff.
- Barbecue Chicken Shake Ups.
- Rip it, pour it, seal and shake it.
- The last thing I want to do is
put barbecue sauce on this,
shake it up, and then eat it.
- It's like watery and
soggy, but I'm so distracted
by the seasoning
- Kids love chicken nuggets.
- I don't like the chicken nuggets.
- If you told a robot, I would like you
to put together a barbecue chicken finger,
this is what that robot would give you.
- I'm gonna go tell my parents
that I finally had Lunchables.
- I'm just gonna eat a lot of salad.
- I don't think that this
qualifies as a lunch.
I'm not sure that it qualifies as food.
- If you're a really busy parent, with
a high powered job,
Lunchables are the way to go.